tenemos la ecuación 20 menos 7 por x es
igual a 6 por x menos 6 y tenemos que
resolver para x a mí me gusta resolver
estas ecuaciones agrupando los términos
constantes que son el 20 y el menos 6 de
un solo lado en este caso los voy a
poner del lado derecho mientras que los
términos en x 7x y 6 x los va a poner
del lado izquierdo así es que para
quitar este 20 del lado izquierdo
voy a restar del lado izquierdo 20 pero
recuerda lo que hago el lado izquierdo
de una ecuación también lo tengo que
hacer del lado derecho
si esto es igual a esto para que se
mantenga la igualdad todo lo que hago
del lado izquierdo tengo que hacerlo
también del lado derecho voy a restar 20
del lado izquierdo también voy a restar
20 del lado derecho así que en el lado
izquierdo de la ecuación nos queda 20 -
20 es igual a 0 se cancelan para eso
hicimos esto no tengo que escribir eso y
tan solo nos queda el lado izquierdo
menos 7 x menos 7 x y eso es igual al
lado derecho de la ecuación donde
tenemos 6
x a lo cual no le estoy restando ni
sumando nada y tenemos menos seis menos
veinte si estamos seis unidades abajo de
cero y tenemos que ir 20 unidades más
abajo llegamos a menos 26 menos 26 ahora
lo siguiente que vamos a hacer es llevar
todas las x del lado izquierdo
no queremos estas 6 x del lado derecho
así es que vamos a restar 6x a ambos
lados restamos 6x del lado derecho y
restamos 6x del lado izquierdo que
obtenemos del lado izquierdo menos 7 x
menos 6x nos da menos 13 x si tenemos
menos 7 de algo a lo cual le restamos 6
de si algo nos resulta menos 13 desde
algo y esto es igual a 6 x menos 6 x se
cancelan ese fue el sentido de hacer
todo esto ya este menos 26 no le estamos
haciendo nada por lo cual nos queda tan
solo menos 26 así es que la ecuación
queda ahora menos 13 x es igual a menos
26 bien
recuerda que nuestra meta es despejar x
y aquí tenemos menos 13 que multiplica x
y la mejor manera de despejar la x es si
tenemos algo que multiplica la x al
dividirlo entre sí algo despejamos la
equis dividimos entonces menos 3 x entre
menos 13 pero ya sabemos que todo lo que
hagamos del lado izquierdo también
tenemos que hacerlo del lado derecho así
es que también necesitamos dividir el
lado derecho entre menos 13 que nos
queda del lado izquierdo menos 13 x
dividido entre menos 13 va a ser
simplemente x si tenemos algo x xy lo
dividimos entre ese mismo algo vamos a
obtener simplemente x esto se canceló y
x va a ser igual a menos 26 dividido
entre menos 13 esto es igual a 2 menos
entre menos es más y 26 dividido entre
32 así es que esta es la solución que
obtuvimos de la ecuación vamos a
verificar la eso es realmente
maravilloso del álgebra que siempre
podemos verificar nuestras soluciones
vamos a sustituir el valor de x2 en la
ecuación original tenemos entonces 20
menos 7 por x x es igual a 2
y esto es igual esto es igual a 6 por
equis hemos encontrado que x es igual a
2 menos
6 vamos a verificar que el lado
izquierdo es igual al lado derecho el
lado izquierdo que no resulta 20 menos 7
por 2 14 20 menos 14 es igual a 6 y del
lado derecho que nos queda 6 por 2 12
menos 6 12 menos 6 es igual a 6 6 es
igual a 6 hemos verificado que x
igualados es la solución de la ecuación